The answer for which column is relatively straightforward. U goes from 0 to 1
and there are 512 columns starting at 0. I multiply the U of 0.02 by 512 and
get 102.4. I drop the fraction to get the texel column. As you'll recall from
an earlier exercise, we drop the fraction. For the row, if I were to make the
lower left corner to be texel 0,0, then we would simply multiply again and be
done. Row 358 would be the answer. However, counting from the upper left corner
is what we want. Think about the relationship. The lower corner's row 0 is the
upper corner's 511, and vice versa. To convert from one to the other, we
subtract the row from 511. For example, row number 1 at the bottom is indeed
row number 510 when counting from the top. Subtracting 358 from 511 gives us
row 153.